113 punto 9% y nosotros ya sabemos qué
significa eso este por ciento significa
por cada 100 así es que si lo
reescribimos tendremos 113 punto 9 por
cada 100 por ciento lo que es igual a
113 punto 9 de 100
o lo podemos llamar también ciento 13.9
entre 100
y para que podamos hacer esta división
realmente lo que haremos es
recorrer
el punto decimal que se encuentra en
este lugar
si nosotros solamente dividiéramos entre
10 recorreremos hacia la izquierda una
sola posición entre 10 pero estamos
dividiendo entre 100 así es que lo
moveremos otra posición y tendremos
entonces
el punto decimal que terminará aquí
1.139 esto qué significa esto significa
que hicimos la división de 113 punto 9
entre 100 recorrimos hacia la izquierda
si nosotros estuviéramos multiplicando
iríamos hacia la derecha pero hay otros
vídeos que darán muchísimo más detalle
al respecto en este momento lo que
estamos poniendo el enfoque es en que si
tenemos un número con punto decimal y
nos representa a un por ciento por cien
haremos la división de ese mismo número
entre 100 y para cuestiones de velocidad
sabremos que recorreremos 12 lugares
hacia la izquierda el punto decimal y
con eso tendremos nuestra respuesta
1.139 y así de rápido hemos acabado